Speaker 1: Let's go next to why don't we go
from Donny from is it pronounced? Visalia,
Visalia? It's Visalia. Visalia, what state
is that in? Patents in California. Oh,
beautiful. Before I did, I also not know
where it was the last time we spoke.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I probably should take
it to the very carrier also mentioned that
they do on Trump mentioning the 17th or
1917 pandemic being connected to Q&A,
and that's what I called last time.
Speaker 1: Beautiful, but what's on
your mind today, anyway?
Speaker 2: I was wondering
what you what your opinion was of Adam Schiff?
As for president, like, I'm not sure if his
policies are really progressive or not, but
I'm curious if he's and if you think he'd
have any interest, how do you think he would do?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Adam Schiff, I find to be an
interesting guy, a very smart, great speaker. Not
the most progressive guy on the face of the Earth.
And he will bump up against anti-Semitism as a
Jewish gentleman. I think that if I were to look
in that direction, I'd be more interested in Jamie
Raskin than Adam Schiff. I think Jamie Raskin is
really a progressive activist. And so
if you said Schiff or Raskin in thinking
about the kind of like, you know, a Jewish
Jewish white guy with that sort of profile,
I think I would lean more Raskin than Schiff.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Okay, great. Well,
that's all I had.
Speaker 1:
All right. Beautiful, short and
sweet. I appreciate the call.